(electronic music)
- There's something I've
been thinking about a lot.
It's this notion of the
clouds and the dirt.
It's kind of like
another version
of my steak and the sizzle.
Meaning I don't spend any time
on the things that don't matter,
and what doesn't
matter is basically
everything in between the
overall vision and strategy
and the real knowledge of it.
(rap music)
I fully believe.
I am bought in that
there's an ROI here.
I don't need the reports,
I don't need Nielsen's,
I don't need seven years later.
You need the life
where if you want to do
something nice for
somebody just based on
what they were going to do nice
for you in return right then,
that wouldn't be a cool world.
But the truth is, the best
relationships are the ones
where you give them something,
and then you start
forming a relationship
that then may
benefit you somewhere
along the line in
the future, got it?
So when I say the
clouds and dirt,
my clouds are,
I'm gonna buy the Jets,
and here's how I'm gonna do it.
That's a global clouds and dirt.
Here's my clouds and
dirt right now,
as where my VaynerMedia
hat all the time.
Like I believe that the
attention of the consumer
is on social networks
from a better value
proposition than it
is in other places.
I like seeing something,
using it, and then making my,
the reason I,
a lot of people are like,
"Man, your predictions are right."
I'm like,"Because they
already happened."
Right, when I'm put at is
seeing something happen,
use it, use it fast,
and then talk about it,
because I believe, right?
I didn't predict that
Vine was gonna do well.
I saw that Vine was doing well.
I spent a lot of
time learning it,
and then I talked about it.
Do I think that billboard's dead?
No, I don't.
But I also think that as I
look at all these people,
they're looking at
their phones, right?
And so, I don't think
it's worth as much.
How can a billboard be
worth the same price today
that it was five years ago,
in a world where
every person here,
when they leave this conference,
when they go in their car,
if they're a passenger,
is looking at their
phone the entire time
until they get to
wherever they're getting.
And they're not
seeing that billboard.
And as a matter of fact,
not only the passenger,
my friends, the drivers...
(audience laughter)
It's scary out there.
I actually have
reverted back to driving
with two hands 'cause I'm
so scared of you jerk-offs.
Because every time I look
to see how many people
are looking at billboards,
what I'm really realizing
is forget about billboards,
nobody's looking
at the fuckin' road.
(audience laughter)
So my philosophy is social
media marketing works
once you know how to do it.
And that's the clouds.
See, I don't think really
that talented in most things.
The only talent that I think
really over indexes for me
when it comes to business
is truly understanding
that innovation
has never cared about anybody.
Entrepreneurs and
CEOs and individuals
make the mistake of being
either romantic or naive
to what's actually
happening around them.
And so what you're gonna
see, and what I'm banking on
for my career over
the next 40 years,
is the emergence of
direct-to-consumer brands
that are gonna be
able to take advantage
of the reality of technology,
but not be held down
by the channel conflict
of the scale that they're at,
and be able to grow
into big businesses
that go direct to consumer.
And then the dirt is the fact
of like all of this that we do.
That I do put out the content.
That I do understand
what dark posts are.
That I understand that
we're talking now about
Pinterest's new ad product,
that I know the details.
The holy grail of
creating the strategy
of the long tail
algorithm search queries
to target to the
amplification of the creative
we create done best is
testing a lot of things
for the first 30, 60,
90, you know,
we're trying to figure out
what those days really are.
It's so early right now.
The real true DR product
in the world right now
is Facebook dark posts,
in social.
I believe that engagement
on Twitter makes sense.
I also then do it.
I mean all the
people that, you know,
it's not about what you
say, it's about engagement.
All these people that have
their strategies on social,
like the amount of social
media gurus that are like,
"Make sure you engage."
Then they don't engage at
all creates a hypocrisy.
That's why I built the
company that I built.
And not a media buying agency.
The variable of conversion
is the creative.
And that is IP.
That is a human IP.
A lot of times, people
don't have one or the other.
They're too stuck
in the minutiae.
They don't see
the bigger picture.
They don't know how to navigate.
Or they get it philosophically,
but they don't have the skills
or the appetite or
the want or the need
to actually be able to do it right.
Either I'm completely crazy,
and I've lost my mind
somewhere along the way,
or shit's hitting the fan.
And opportunity is striking.
And my guess is it's the latter.
You know the details?
Know the philosophy?
Then don't worry about all
the minutiae in the middle.
The politics, the process,
all the crap that does not matter.
And that's it.
I spend all my time in
the clouds and the dirt
and that's why
I think I'm successful.
I play at the extreme
levels of high buy-in,
and then dedication
to learning my craft.
Clouds, dirt.
(gentle music)